hi I'm Charley day and I'm gonna be
wired complete what is it what are we
doing so wired autocomplete interview
here goes burning question is Charley
day a Democrat this is people's top
concern honestly I don't know what I am
sometimes I'm a Democrat sometimes I'm
not I don't care if you're someone who
cares about what I care about don't care
cuz I don't care if you want to know how
I feel about politics I'm against it is
Charlie day a smoker I'm not a smoker
guys it'll give you cancer was that a
democratic answer I don't know
is Charlie Day related to Steve Carell I
don't think so
I'm gonna guess no but what maybe we
should do some DNA research it's Charlie
day Canadian I'm not Canadian but I've
been to Canada and I liked it a lot and
I love to find people of Canada so
that's a compliment is Charlie Day
hidden Star Wars no no that is John
boyega you got the two of us mixed up
again there's more all right can Charlie
die can Charlie Day I skate yes I can I
skate played hockey in high school can
Charlie Day actually play the piano I
can't actually play the piano I couldn't
play in Carnegie Hall but I can pluck
out a tune Charlie Day can you imagine I
get it man no I can't imagine but it
happened folks where did Charlie Day go
to college I went to Merrimack College
in North Andover Massachusetts where
this Charlie Day live I live in Los
Angeles most of the time where did
Charlie Day grow up I grew up in
Middletown Rhode Island where Charley
day uh this is Charlie day good question
does Charlie day have a twitter I do not
have a Twitter don't care for it Twitter
ruining the world twitter is uh this
Charlie Day have siblings I have an
older sister
what does Charlie Day say huh you
googled what does Charlie Day say he
says what are you talking about man does
Charlie Day play hockey a lot of hockey
questions
did play some hockey in my heyday I
don't play hockey anymore just totally
des have a PhD I do have a PhD I have an
honorary PhD from Merrimack College
myself Mike Tyson and Kermit the Frog
Charlie Day I have a brother I do not
have a brother that I know of
how much does Charlie day away well
that's depends it's been somewhere
around 150 pounds give or take does
Charlie dare you a our eyeliner I do not
wear eyeliner I was born with very dark
lines under my eyes and and I got teased
about it and I my childhood but no I
don't want her what was Charlie they
remind me of I'm gonna say that's
probably Brad Pitt where does Charlie
Day get his shirts this one's from a
company called Vince how about that I
love these questions when did Charlie
Day graduate college in 1998 when did
Charlie Day meet his wife in December of
2001 when did Charlie Day get married
March 4th 2006 why do people want to
know all this stuff I'm feeling violated
when uh what Charlie Day vacation every
now and that I really start to worry
about people uh when Charlie Day
vacation when he gets some free time
that when Charlie Day vacation what
Charlie Day what is Charlie Day for real
life probably exactly what you'd expect
what height is Charlie Day I'm just
about a smidge under five seven I didn't
quite make it to five seven and my
dreams were crushed
what is the tattoo on Charlie days arm
it's my character on It's Always Sunny
in Philadelphia statue and he tried to
tattoo bad news on his arm but it hurt
too much and he also spelled it wrong so
the tattoo says bad new what color
choices eyes they're greenish what shoes
does Charlie Day wear sneakers dress
shoes boots and gym shoes does Charlie
Day do
stand up I do not stand up I'll leave
that to the professionals this early day
have a kid I do have a child I'm a daddy
who Charlie Day who was Charlie day in
the Legos movie Legos plural
I was Benny the space guy who does
Charlie Day sound like god forbid any
other poor soul who plays Charlie days
boss I guess if it's Horrible Bosses it
was Jennifer Aniston who Charlie Day
commencement speech the who was me I
gave a commencement speech at Merrimack
College the the who I guess was the
college and the who was you can find it
on the Internet what is that question
who is Charlie Day his father that would
be Thomas day is Charlie Day is Charlie
Day in new girl I've never been in the
show new girl it's Charlie day atheist
that's loaded I don't know agnostic
maybe it's Charlie Day from Philadelphia
I'm not from Philadelphia I born in New
York City and then I grew up in Rhode
Island my dad's from Philly though I got
family there
Sharleen a left-handed I am right-handed
it's Charlie day in the notebook yes
that was me in the notebook and Ryan
Gosling he filled in for like a scene
but mostly that was my performance hey
guys thanks for googling me and I hope
that I answered all your burning
questions and just to reiterate once
again yes that was me in the notebook